es ist wirklich nicht untertrieben zu
sagen der größte anzunehmende unfall bei
facebook hat stattgefunden der absolute
supergau und das wirklich schlimme seit
2005 10 seit rund drei jahren ist es von
facebook bekannt aber der konzern hat
nichts effektives unternommen was
passiert ist recherchen der new york
times und des britischen guardian zu
haben ergeben gegen die
nutzungsbedingungen des internetkonzerns
wurden private daten abgeschöpft und mit
anderen daten kombiniert und offenbar
zur gezielten beeinflussung von facebook
nutzern eingesetzt was genau passiert
ist und für wen die daten gefällig sind
jetzt ein klick zum zweiten fiction
herzlich willkommen
das hätte wirklich nicht passieren
dürfen und was es noch schlimmer macht
facebook war dieses furchtbare datenleck
bekannt und das unternehmen hat nichts
effektives dagegen unternommen
da ist es dem konzern scheinbar lieber
keinen wirbel und schlechte pr zu haben
als ein datenleck nachhaltig zu
schließen
es ist wirklich absolut grauenhaft und
die folgen dazu der reihe nach
recherchiert haben die new york times
und der britische guardian hinter dem
massenhaften datenmissbrauch steckt die
britische firma cambridge analytiker sie
will einen algorithmus entwickelt haben
der in der lage ist aus ein paar likes
auf facebook exakt geschlecht sexuelle
orientierung und und das ist wichtig
politische einstellung zu errechnen
diesen algorithmus hat die firma auf die
profile von millionen us wlan angewandt
um die us-wahl gezielt zu beeinflussen
sie arbeiteten dafür eng mit dem team
und wer hätte sich da jetzt gewundert
von donald trump zusammen und und jetzt
können wir alle mal innehalten die firma
hat in großbritannien die probe exit
kampagne unterstützt
es liegt also nicht fern zu vermuten
dass der algorithmus von cambridge
analytiker bei der knappen entscheidung
der knappen backseat entscheidung das
zünglein an der waage war wenn nicht
sogar mehr eine absolute katastrophe wir
würden dem unternehmen eine massive
schädigung des euroraums verdanken die
am ende wohl millionen kosten wird um
wahlen zu beeinflussen sammelt cambridge
analytiker daten um damit
persönlichkeitsprofile anzulegen dass es
absolut verboten damit lassen sich
nutzer besonders gezielt mit genau den
richtigen botschaften ansprechen um sie
zu beeinflussen
gegründet wurde die firma von hedgefonds
mit der roboter einem glühenden trump
unterstützer steven bällen der ehemalige
chef berater und breitbart chefredakteur
saß im aufsichtsrat trotz aufforderung
von facebook hat die firma die
abgeschöpften daten bisher nicht
gelöscht so die recherche von new york
times unsere guardian dabei wurden die
daten über die unterschiedlichsten
methoden abgeerntet
war die app this is your social life
getarnt als research app die vom
psychologen genutzt wird mit der app
gaben nutzer die erlaubnis daten von
facebook wie wohnort und likes
abzugreifen
die app sammelte aber offenbar darüber
hinaus auf diesem weg auch die daten von
facebook freunden und den kontakten dass
es verboten
trotz aufforderung so das ergebnis der
recherche wurden die daten bisher nicht
gelöscht facebook hat jetzt den account
von strategic communications aber tories
inhaber von cambridge analytiker sowie
die profile der mittäter alexandra
kugeln und christoph meili gesperrt sie
hatten beide als psychologen für
cambridge analytiker gearbeitet
die staatsanwaltschaft des bundesstaates
massachusetts nahm jetzt die ermittlung
auf die britischen datenschutz behörden
kündigten eine untersuchung von facebook
an
und ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum
thema facebook datenleck und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp dann
erfährt er von mir vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion von
krieg so mitmachen und mit themen zb
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und so direkt mitbestimmen
was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte
draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
das ist der direkte link und natürlich
nicht das aber mit der genau glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter dafür auch
drauf klicken
teslas sind datenkraken er ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran